welcome back myth chasers
it's time to test more of your myths and
theories in the ever-changing world of
fortnite battle royale
simply leave a myth in the comments
below and upvote your favorites
and we'll waste our time to test them
ready for next week
do me a favor and click subscribe if you
haven't already and think about leaving
a like as that helps more than you know
you ready let's do this as the unvaulted
game mode has returned we can go back to
some myths that haven't been possible
for almost a year
like this one can a junk rift break open
a vault
i jumped into a game and picked up a
junk rift the junk rift has a random
chance of dropping a selection of items
from an anchor
to a car to a triceratops and of course
the sacred porta potty i made my way
over to the agency
and tried to break open the vault
yeah no this is not gonna work i tried
this with other vaults too
and although we can hear the loot inside
sadly we cannot get that metal block
open without a keycard
or a glitch to make sure of this i also
tried other items you guys have
suggested in the past
including a portaforge it actually takes
the vault door but instead of replacing
the structure
it shares the wall in between and you
get this anomaly where we can see
part of the vault handle through the
metal and for extra proof
i edited the wall to see if that was the
key to opening the vault door
but nope there it is still standing
strong then i decided to try the boom
box
this item is designed to smash buildings
to the ground
and well yeah see for yourself the sound
does ripple through and
into the vault but the boom box does not
open the door
so simply put nothing is breaking open
this vault door today
we are not going to be bank robbers
today but whilst we're talking about
myths about junk rifts check this one
out what happens when the last two
people die
to a junk rift what do you think will
happen once the junk rift is activated
who will win for this one a friend and i
perfectly lined up together and threw
down
one of those junk rifts
and as you can see it isn't possible to
draw a game using junk rifts
we tried this again but this time i
threw the rift and once again
this happened it looks like either a
random selection
or there's a minute difference in the
two characters placements
but either way myth busted two solo
players cannot be killed by the junk
rift
at the end of the game just in case you
require more proof we added a third
person to our game
their job was to throw down the junk
rift to show that this
is not biased in any way and then
quickly run over
and eliminate themselves on this lovely
track wall
what a good job that person got anyway
here's what happened
[Music]
completely random choice of who will win
the game
here's a nice easy one
[Music]
what happens when a flare gun shoots
another flare gun
i'm taking this to mean what happens
when the bullets collide
rather than the fly guns themselves let
me know if i've misunderstood the myth
so anyway we jumped into game once again
and found the items we needed
and this was actually really difficult
to get the shots lined up we had no idea
if the bullets were hitting each other
and if they did they passed straight
through in-game
so i loaded up the replay file and the
bullets act as if there is nothing there
in front of them
and continue on their journey so another
fail to add to our collection
we need a success and i think i have it
now
and this is possibly my favorite myth
ever
can an upgrade bench prevent a reboot
what a great idea upgrade benches to
stop people from being rebooted
here's the premise by finding or
knocking down an upgrade bench
we can then place it on top of the
reboot van and hopefully
stop that person from respawning in that
spot
will it work i dived into game again
with a couple of guys i'm building a
creative map with
i'll tell you more about that next month
we landed together and claimed the
nearest upgrade bench
then i placed it on the reboot van next
point we had to sacrifice a friend
we've all been there right it's for a
good cause we then waited for the reboot
to happen
and believe me it's worth it check this
i can't believe it it actually works the
player is stuck inside the upgrade bench
and in some situations is trapped in a
skydive or a glider deploy
if their feet connect with the reboot
van they are able to break free using
their pickaxe
but by the time they've done that their
immunity is gone
so using this in-game is a legit real
option
even if it doesn't catch out a foe it
will force the team to break the bench
before rebooting
and thus makes them easier to hunt down
or prepare
to ambush so we decided to take this
myth further and invited another person
into the game
i immediately murderized them it's okay
it's for myth chasing purposes we try to
see if two players could be trapped
inside one bench that's a weird sentence
here's what happened
hmm so not as planned one of the players
spawned off center and was freed
so then we tried this again with two
upgrade benches on top
here's what happened when two players
are rebooted with two benches
stacked above them
it works they are both trapped inside
the bench
this is my kind of ridiculous thank you
fortnight
top quality content we tried this with
three people
but sadly it didn't work one and
sometimes two and occasionally all three
players
spawned outside the usual spot but
theoretically
this could trap more actual players i am
very tempted to try this with a full
lobby
but for now it certainly works on one
player and could work on many more so
it's a good tactic
and for you memes you could even hide
inside here to see if anybody notices
you
and then make a youtube video and go
viral or troll your friends
both are great options
here's another brilliant myth what
happens when two teams reboot
at exactly the same time wow
this is this is really interesting two
teams using the same reboot van
at exactly the same moment what will
happen will both teams be rebooted
or maybe neither so let's try it for
this one we were joined by famous
youtuber teased
and we set up into two teams of two
people we then murderized one of each
team and then coordinated the exact
moment we were going to press square
and reboot our friends who's your money
on me or him
i well wow so the first time
it was my enemy who had their partner
rebooted which meant
my guy never actually showed up again
sad times
so we tried this again and this time
my partner came back and the other
persons didn't so this shows us that
whatever happens one team can only be
rebooted at once
looking back at the replay files and
yeah a few times we were a few
milliseconds out in our reboot
attempts but on one single occasion we
started the reboot
at the very same time the exact same
frame
completely in sync i honestly didn't
think we could do that so well
so this is 100 proof that two teams
cannot reboot at the same time
the game randomly picks one team to get
the edge and therefore get the reboot
this myth is busted but that was a great
myth all the same gg
okay a couple of fun myths to end
remember the pet back blings
yeah me too i personally like the pink
hamster and remember we could pet them
in game the hamster gets very happy by
the way
well check out this myth from pika for
owner
weird name who says can we pet the pet
of a decoy okay let's break that down i
believe they'd like us to try and throw
down a decoy
and then pet that [ __ ] or lizard or
hamster this is a weird sentence
for this one the setup was simple i wore
my favorite hamster back bling
and threw down a decoy and asked a
friend to chase them down
look he's literally myth chasing yeah
he somehow caught up and proved this
myth right but it didn't look too great
so i suggest
throwing down a wall as that's the far
easier option to get this
but a weird myth proven nonetheless you
can indeed
pet the pet of a decoy
so there we have it another bunch of
myths from you guys thank you to
everyone who offered ideas without you
this series is nothing i'll be in the
comments below looking for great myths
for the next video
which is all about vehicles make them
some really weird myths please i'd love
to try them out
on screen now are the next bunch of code
adamaru legends thank you so much for
using my code and then sending me a dm
on twitter
it's much appreciated it makes a huge
difference to what i'm able to do
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure i'll see you for the
update on tuesday
[Music]
you